is uh the adoption of the agenda is
there any request any problem for you I
cannot see that and in so far uh I
declare the agenda for adopted my
announcements number two of today yes
you know our meeting is as usual webst
streamed we have interpretation
available in English French German
Italian Dutch Greek Spanish Portuguese
Swedish Hungarian polish and Romanian
and you need to know that our guests um
online can only rely on a
qualified uh
translation if the sound and the video
of remote
participants um is properly set up in
order to get our messages across Please
be aware that phone interventions and
audio only connections will not be inter
interpreted number three the workshop on
forcible transfer and deportation of
Ukrainian
children responses and accountability
measures dear colleagues this Workshop
comes very timely after our recent visit
to the
Ukraine two weeks ago in Kiev we
discussed extensively with civil society
and authorities the forcible transfer
and deportation of Ukrainian children by
Russia as well as the situation of
civilians in the occupied Ukrainian
territories today we will be able to
exchange further in a debate with
experts on the respective
topics in March 23 we had an exchange of
views on the violation of international
law regarding the forceable
deportation our purpose today is to
assess the progress and the challenges
regarding accountability measures as
well as Ukrainian European and
international efforts to protect and to
repatriate Children our subcommittee
intends to be as operational as possible
I have the pleasure to First welcome the
two authors of the briefings and
umland on my left hand side will focus
on International responses to the
forceable transfer and unlawful
deportation of Ukrainian children we
look forward to you telling us more
about the progress of existing
repatriation initiatives including their
challenges and gaps as well as your very
recommendations Miss Julia Yer will tell
us more about the progress of the
ongoing efforts to ensure accountability
for the crimes committed against
Ukrainian children by Russian Authority
welcome as well this is part of a
broader reflection on the effectiveness
of these mechanisms including the ICC
Universal jur jurisdiction in member
states the role of eurojust and domestic
Pro persecutions in the
Ukraine that was a major part of our
conversations also uh with our hosts in
the Ukraine to find ways to follow up
with the appropriate uh judical measures
uh given a situation in a
country uh which builds up its
capacities knowing also about their
shortages both draft briefings have been
distributed of our guests here to
members before this meeting and are
available in the room in printed form as
well I have the huge pleasure to
remotely welcoming mikola kulba former
commissioner of the president of Ukraine
for children's rights and
co-founder of the alliance for Ukraine
without offense and save
Ukraine we had the pleasure and the
chance to meet Mr kba in the
Ukraine in one of his premises and I'm
delighted that he could accept to share
his important work with us in this
meeting today Mr kba is connecting from
London his time will be very limited
therefore we will take a first round of
questions right after his intervention
to allow him to
reply finally as the second part of our
Workshop we will broaden our perspective
from the unlawful transfer and the
deportation of children to the situation
of Ukrainian civilian prisoners we will
hear from Anna wri Regional researcher
expert of Ukraine for Amnesty
International who visited Ukraine
recently and is in contact with
testimonies and victim Vic IMS of atals
deportations and finally the European
parliament's vice president and
coordinators for the right of the child
Miss kobach cannot be present today but
addressed a
message uh to the audience from which I
will quote after Mr kba's intervention
but now it's my pleasure to give the
floor for our guest speakers Andreas
uman for 8 minutes minutes
please thank you very much um there
would have been a good reason to let
here um a Ukrainian speaker to be first
um but um perhaps I'm the political
analyst on this panel and what is needed
is first a political um
contextualization what what we're
talking here about um Ukrainian
colleague of mine also political
scientist Tana feduk has in a report for
the talin
International Center for defense and
security uh titled one of the
subheadings of her report on this
particular issue too cruel to be
true too cruel to be true is I think
something that uh we as researchers have
also experienced here and um to
understand um why so much cruelty to
children is done is I think uh um it is
NE NE to put it in the political
ideological historical context within
which Russia is doing this um as an
introduction maybe um one um needs to
first uh distinguish um um Professor
Bulman already mentioned the forcable
transfers different kinds of forcable
transfers so we distinguish in our
reports about uh between on the one hand
displaced children who remain on the
legal territory of Ukraine but are not
deported to Russia and uh on the other
hand and perhaps Julia will then correct
me or specify this further um deported
children who are taken from Ukrainian
territory and brought on the territory
of the Russian Federation another um
important distinction is that between
accompanied children who uh are
displaced or deported with their legal
Guardians with their parents or other
legal Guardians and un ACC compan um
children of which there are also a lot
who um are forcibly
transferred this um terminological
distinction and conceptual distinction
is uh already making things rather
complicated what is making things even
more complicated is that we are
operating in a plethora of different
statistical evaluations and um numbers
that are circulating in the media partly
spread uh by Russia that has sort of
tried to inflate the numbers of actually
uh forcibly transferred uh children by
bringing up particularly High numbers
and we we are um discussing among
ourselves how how Russia came up with
these high numbers one suspicion that I
have is here that they have simply
counted in also um for instance the
children of Labor migrants thereby sort
of trying to diffuse um the attention
and and make it all look in a very
different way the um the number that uh
is most easily usable here is the one
from the children of War website of the
Ukrainian government where we have
approximately the the data on 20,000 uh
children uh where we have where there is
a verification process already underway
and where we are certain that we can
speak about um this number but this
number maybe actually and Julia or
mikola or Anna Maybe commenting on this
um too low um the political um aspect
that I mentioned at the beginning and
that is I think crucial for
understanding here is has a whole number
of um um Dimensions that sort of explain
the cruelty of um of the actions by
Russia and the most important one here
is perhaps the ideology of P Russian ISM
and the idea of pan Russian ISM in a
very short formula say among others has
spoken about this is that there is no
Ukrainian State there is no Ukrainian
Nation this is actually Western Russia
and so the outrageous things are
happening from a Russian point of view
from the Russian leadership points of
view actually within Russia these are
actually Russians that have been
miseducated that have have been um
manipulated by the west by Ukrainian
nationalists and therefore international
law does not really apply to them
because they are part of the Russian
Nation there's also a different argument
here about protecting these children
from Ukrainian fascism an alleged
Ukrainian fascism an alleged Civil War
that started in
2014 protecting them from Western
decadence from
transgender ideology LGBT and what not
you you have probably heard about this
so this is I think this um this context
within which the Russian actors operate
here and which I think explains the um
the cruelty and the um the Unapologetic
behavior of the uh Russian lead
leadership yet another aspect of this um
of this political context is the in
generally uh instrumental approach that
the Soviet regime and also the
post-soviet Russian regime has towards
children one expression of this also
mentioned by the already mentioned
Tatiana feduk in her report is the Dima
yakovlev law from 2012 some of you may
have heard of it that was a response by
Russia to the magnitsky ACT and that
forbade foreigners to adopt children um
from Russia and and actually it was
mainly about um sick children that were
mainly adopted by Foreign citizens and
um and so this was against the interests
of these Russian childrens um often very
sick children who have remained as a
result of this of this law in Russian um
children homes rather than being um
adopted yet another political aspect is
um that the war that Russia is has been
conducting against um Ukraine since 2014
and which has escalated in 2024 is not
only a geographic war and not only a war
for Geographic con Conquest it's also a
war of demographic Conquest it's about
not only the territory of the Ukraine
Ians but it's about the ukrainians
themselves that are to be conquered and
then made into into Russians to be
brought back to the real Russ Russian
identity as mentioned um these uh uh
already indicated already these
deportations and displacements have been
already taking place since 2014 on much
smaller scale then but uh and they have
escalated since
2022 and um there are the different um I
think Julia is going to and and mola and
Anna perhaps will also talk about that
the different categories here the
children of war that have been picked up
um in the in the war zone the uh from
children from institutions uh from
holiday camps and so on um I will not
perhaps deal with that too much here and
go over to the um U to the political
recommendations that I've outlined also
in the in the written uh briefings so
there has been um a huge Gap I would say
over the last uh almost two years now
between the many International
statements uh that we have seen from uh
International U um and National also
institutions and and the lack of of of
action or lack of effective
effectiveness of action and that has to
that has to um to change and there are
basically two strategies here uh shaming
and blaming um um uh campaign and uh um
Shadow di diplomacy I I see these two
instruments as the main here the shadow
diplomacy is maybe the most obvious one
it's using mediators um usually
non-western States neutral
NOS religious labor and other NOS as
mediators to bring children back from
Russia to Ukraine a number of um rather
surprising uh also states have become
engaged in mediating this
um turkey Saudi Arabia have have engaged
in this uh Ukraine has requested the um
the assistance of the Vatican and the uh
Emirate of Qatar has actually had some
success in bringing back four children
from Russia to Ukraine um in my
interviews in Ukraine I've also uh come
across hopes from ukrainians who have
said that perhaps countries like
Kazakhstan India or South Africa who are
with with you with Russia in
international organizations like the
Eurasian economic Union or the brics
group could could help in bringing back
um children and also what I would also
suggest is that here um um the European
Parliament uh or people around um the
Parliament and within the EU could use
remaining links with governmental and
non-governmental actors in um in uh
Russia to perhaps facilitate a
repatriation and also perhaps first to
identify where the children are and
which children have been deported do I
still have a minute um yeah so um but
that is only one I think side of the uh
of this whole thing the uh the shadow
diplomacy the uh inclusion of mediators
in order to bring actually um children
back unless the Russian regime changes
radically um and it could happen
actually there are actually now signs uh
during the last month
um like for instance expressed by the
prian Mutiny that perhaps the regime
will change sooner or later but as long
as the current regime is in um is in
place we need International pressure
massive much more massive International
pressure uh by a variety of
international and National institutions
uh to bring attention to the issue and
to exert um then this pressure on the uh
Russian government and I'm following
here largely the the lead of a Ukrainian
NGO called the regional center for human
rights which is one of the major
Ukrainian NOS that has been uh making
proposing in in this direction for
instance um that there should be more ad
hoc resolutions as the European
Parliament has already uh initiated but
also um the US Senate Slovakia that
would specifically deal um with the
deported and displaced children that
would not simply have a section um in a
larger resolution with a larger agenda
where this issue would be mentioned but
where you would actually have specific
res resolutions by um International
assemblies by national parliaments who
would address that and the most uh
important one would be here of course
the United Nations General Assembly um
the regional center for human rights of
Ukraine has also um suggested that
sanctions should be extended the circle
the scope of the sanctions should be
extended there should be also
institutional sanctions against entities
um in Russia that have part Taken part
in the deportation and russification of
Ukrainian children's camps schools
universities and so on um there's a hope
for new indictments from the
international criminal court or other
courts there and and Julia and others
will be more competent to speak about
this um um there is also um in the
report that I've presented um the
suggestion that we need more research
simply we need more more knowledge on
what what uh what is actually happening
Julia myself we have only been able to
cover a certain part of the uh and
there's also I should also mention there
has been a previous report by the
European parliamentary research service
that um has been published a few months
ago and on which we we are building here
what we could need for instance is a is
a more comprehensive and detailed
register of the deported and displaced
children in fact a research project that
would specifically um focus on on uh
finding these childrens because Ukraine
has has limited uh resources to do that
now as long as it is at War what we
would also need could also need is um
something like a perpetrator study
there's a a sub discipline in genocide
studies called perpetrator studies which
focuses on on the people who are U
committing uh uh these crimes and um who
are engaged in the deportations in the
russification and so on uh so that would
be another thing that could be um useful
and also something similar perhaps in
his in historical and um political sense
to what ulia has already done maybe she
namely she has um looked uh on the um on
the uh deportations from the point of
from a legal comparative Viewpoint and
she will present herself what he has she
has found out what we need also is to
look at it from a historical from a
political comparative uh perspective to
uh to contextualize what we are uh
seeing now in Russia um in a larger
field of uh uh of sort of of the study
of of deportation namely and and um and
displacement of of children we need
awareness Rising for uh campaigns for
Ukrainian families in um in Ukraine so
that that they do not go in get into
this trap of for instance sending their
children to to Holiday camps or
something like that and we need above
all awareness Rising for the broader
public u in not only in the west but
worldwide what I see here is there is
actually a lot of knowledge accumulated
about these this uh issue but it's
mainly limited to a circle of diplomats
experts people here in the European
Parliament of uh um of students of this
of this topic but the broader public is
is perhaps not sufficiently um aware of
that we need uh journalists editors
bloggers Publishers pundits artists and
so on to to document what is happening
for a broader public so that actually
people become aware of it and and um
that we actually um can say it is cruel
but it is true it's not too cruel uh to
be true and maybe I end on this
thanks very much Andrea zland Andreas is
Analyst at the Stockholm Center for
Eastern European studies at the Swedish
Institute of international Affairs and
he requests us not only to fact find but
also to talk about it this is exactly
what we are doing uh with reference also
to the mission we had and I will now
give the floor to Julia assistant
professor in law at University College
London for the same amount of
time perfect uh thank you so much uh
it's an honor to be here and thank you
to Dr umland to provide for providing
such a comprehensive uh uh political
context I will focus on the legal
analysis uh and will present to you some
of the findings with regard to forcable
transfers of Ukrainian children to
Russia and uh whether it violates any
international law provisions but what I
will focus on uh is accountability
mechanisms uh that can be used to
litigate this issues under international
law and of course we'll try to uh
pinpoint some of the limitations of this
accountability mechanisms so generally
under uh international law and in
particular International humanitarian
law law of armed conflict uh forceable
transfers and deportations of Civilian
population uh is prohibited and of
course children are part of Civilian
population
uh additional protocol one to the Geneva
conventions also mentions that
evacuations sometimes are possible of
children uh but they can be uh only
temporary and only for compelling
reasons of health and safety of children
and even if that's possible children
should be returned to the country of uh
citizenship or to the neutral country
and Russia of course is not such country
and even if such situation exists there
are strict conditions that uh the
occupying power that is evacuating
children should abide by which include
family unification providing education
at the same level and we have a lot of
evidence saying that Russia doesn't
conform uh to uh these conditions uh
additionally some of the instruments of
international human rights law are
relevant here for example the convention
on the rights of the child uh has a
number of Provisions that concerns the
identity of children and uh uh family
unity and unfor fortunately these uh
haven't been preserved with regard to
Ukrainian children so uh it is very
likely that articles uh 7 8 9 10 and 16
of the convention on the right of child
would also be violated in this case and
all this violations also lead to
individual criminal responsibility under
the Rome statute of the international
criminal court uh and could be qualified
as a war crime crime against humanity
and even genocide uh speaking of
accountability
mechanisms uh it appears that Ukraine uh
PRI has prioritized the international
criminal court uh and litigation of this
specific issue before the international
criminal court president zansky met with
prosecutor Han and highlighted and
emphasized that it is uh extremely
important for the future generations of
ukrainians to return children who were
deported uh as everyone knows on 17th of
April uh 2023 uh the IC issued two
arrest warrants with regard to President
Putin and the children's rights
commissioner Maria Lova belova uh and
qualified this crimes as war crimes of
forcable transfer uh but again this
doesn't have to be the end of the route
uh there were examples in previous
practice of the IC where they added
additional charges or requalified uh
certain crimes so it is still possible
uh to qualify uh uh this violations as
crime against Humanity or as genocide
Ukraine also has brought a case before
the international court of justice based
on the uh genocide convention however it
doesn't uh pertain specifically to uh
forceable transfer of children the claim
is about false claim of genocide so that
Russia used the false claim of genocide
of Russian speaking uh people in donbas
and in this way used it as a pretext of
illegal use of force uh of course
Ukraine can uh expand this claim and
also claim that uh Russia is committing
an actual genocide on the territory of
Ukraine by forcibly transferring
Ukrainian children but Ukraine hasn't
taken the step yet but it is still
possible uh there has been a lot of uh a
lot has been done also on domestic level
so the member states of the EU uh
initiated investigations under the
universal jurisdiction particularly
Germany Lithuania Sweden um Spain
started the investigations into war
crimes and crimes against uh Humanity
there are no for now claims of genocide
yet but this uh efforts are expanding
and the Ukraine and the office of
prosecutor uh have been very active in
trying to prosecute International crimes
that were committed on the territory of
Ukraine uh the prosecutor is pursuing at
least 20 cases related to forcable
transfers of ukrainians citizens and uh
in June 2023 Ukrainian persecutors B
brought the first charges against
forceable transfers of Ukrainian
children from Heron uh orphanage and the
crime at least alleged crime right now
is uh the war crime uh one limitations
uh of the domestic trials uh is that a
lot of them are conducted In Absentia so
the uh alleged perpetrators are not in
hands of Ukraine many of them are either
on occupied territory or in Russia so
that has been a challenge for
prosecuting both in Ukraine but also
Under Universal jurisdiction in the uh
EU member states uh of course European
Union uh has done quite a lot in this
regard as well there is a number of
resolution of European Parliament Dr
umland mentioned them uh there is also
efforts by eurojust that are leading
efforts especially with regard to
collecting evidence by establishing
joint investigation teams and the core
International crimes evidence database
uh there are some efforts uh that have
been pursued uh in Council of Europe but
of course uh a limitation of that route
is that Russia is no longer is a member
uh of Council of Europe and for example
European Court of human rights has
jurisdiction including for forcible
transfer of Ukrainian children on until
16th September 2022 and uh it is uh
questionable whether this route is the
most effective one considering the
tensions between Russia and European
Court of Human Rights even before the uh
full scale invasion of Ukraine so uh
there are other mechanisms of course and
I will refer you to the briefing to look
into them in more detail but I
identified four main challenges and uh
unfortunately the the biggest one is
that international law doesn't have
doesn't provide for the mechanism of
Return of children uh it it is always
easier to prevent this kind of event
then try to uh address the uh
consequences so locating children and
ensuring their return is uh the biggest
uh issue uh another um challenge to
accountability is access to territory as
I mentioned because of perpetrators are
in Russian occupied territory uh or in
Russia similarly Witnesses and some of
the evidence so uh to pursue legal Roots
uh this is a significant limitation uh
third thir uh challenge to
accountability is coordination and
financing as I've uh uh tried to briefly
give you an overview the system for
litigating these claims is quite
fragmented both both in international
law but also domestically so it does
require a lot of coordination and uh
finances and making sure that uh the
same efforts are not repeated and of
course uh there are some roots that
already Dr mland mentioned that are
Beyond uh the legal rot so negotiations
some of them can complement uh
litigation in domestic courts and
international court so given the
constraints of international law and
achieving accountability there should be
a coordinated approach both in domestic
and international levels and some of the
recommendations that I would suggest is
refining the litigation strategies so
figuring out which crime should be
pursued War crime crime against humanity
or genocide and focusing evidence
collection on that issue uh encouraging
close cooperation in relation to
evidence uh enhance utilization of
universal jurisdiction and coordinated
approach uh to financing thank
you thank you so much uh
Julia our two experts and you can read
the studies uh printed or
online
um have
described the fact finding Di
mention have proposed possible
improvements but have also frankly been
speaking about the difficulties in this
International environment of
crime Mr kba we visited you we had the
chance to talk to you to hear from
you how and in what kind of
extensive way
Against All
Odds you are
using your room for
maneuver and perhaps even much more than
your room for maneuver visiting you and
visiting children you brought back and
your organization brought back I would
like to say it was the highlight of our
visit in the
Ukraine because we saw
how
practices as described here could also
been overcome to give a
future to the children and the future to
the nation we are Keen to hearing from
you thanks for sharing your time with us
we are Keen to hearing from you about
your practices about your experiences
but also about your expectations what we
could do and what international
organizations could do to support you
please you have the
floor thank you so much Professor
Bullman and dear ladies and gentlemen I
am deeply grateful for the opportunity
to speak before you and you are very
well informed what happened with
Ukrainian children and just now Dr
umland talked about this very clear and
my main message now is simple the
Russian Federation is committing
genocide of the Ukrainian Nation by
forcibly forcibly transferring our
children to Russia and annihilating
their Ukrainian identity now I'm in
British Parliament raising awareness
about these issues and together with me
is two girls whove been returned and um
Professor Bulman you've seen them in our
hope and Healing Center you met there
and you talk with them and they are
sharing their stories here and in
British Parliament and now a little just
to a little structure and to go deeply
in Ukrainian history and this story of
Russian genocide against the Ukrainian
people doesn't begin on the
24th of
February 202 to with the invasion of
crania in
2014 it began almost 100 years ago in
the early
1930s the Soviet Union was a fledgling
Empire looking to consolidate its grip
on its reluctant republics while the
Soviet Force collectivization across the
Empire Soviet Ukraine was subjected to a
series of special and part
particularly little administrative
policies including the ceiling of its
Border in
1932 33 nearly 4 million people
perished entire Villages were silenced
by by by
starvation on some of the most fertile
land on Earth my grandmother was one of
13 siblings 11 of whom died in this
man-made famine the homore this was just
the first of many attempts to
destroy eliminate the Ukrainian Nation
the parallels between that and now are
undeniable Putin set the stage for this
current genocide when he denied the very
existence of the Ukrainian people and
Ukrainian language in his now
Infamous Manifesto from July 2021 in
which he refers to Russians and
ukrainians as quote a single
whole the current regime in Moscow uses
the same language and narratives now as
the Soviet Union did then to rationalize
its genocidal act in the 1930s
propaganda posters called for the
annihilation of the kulaks which became
synonymous with Ukrainian pents Lenin
called them blood blood suckers or
vampires today in 2023 Russian State
television presents ukrainians as a
Peaks as a parasites and worms Putin
regime has brainwashed a nation in its
efforts to destroy it another its goal
is genocide and it's unmitigated evil
but today's genocidal plan does not rely
on death camps or forced famine anymore
though scores of ukrainians are dying
every day both wordss and actions of
Russian officials indicate they intend
to separate Ukrainian children
permanently from their families their
National and ethnic group and thereby
annihilate their Ukrainian identity Mara
belova you mentioned her bred about
740,000 Ukrainian children being
forcibly transferred Ukrainian officials
openly expressed the intent to have the
transferred Ukrainian children educated
in the Russian language adopted into
Russian families and turned into Russian
citizens to codify and expedite this
this genocidal aim a draft law was
introduced in the Russian Parliament
which provides for a simplified
procedure for adoption of forcefully
displaced Ukrainian children by Russian
families at the same time Russia has
been issuing Russian birth certificates
to Ukrainian and children in the
territories under its control also an
investigation conducted by the Yale
University established that the deported
Ukrainian children were kept in Russian
control reeducation camps save Ukraine
my organization has rescued more than
200 forcibly transferred children we not
only return this children to Ukraine but
we provide both physical and
psychological support to help them them
heal from their traumas though each
child story is unique we have heard
several common themes from the
experiences that tell us about life for
hundreds of thousands of Ukrainian
children living in Russian control
territories of or Russia itself we don't
know how many of these children are
unaccompanied but we know that
unaccompanied children are the most
vulnerable to Total identity
Erasure we have heard again and again
about the clear and systematic
destruction of Ukrainian identity and
Dear Professor you heard this in our
hoben Healing Center children are forced
to listen to Russian propaganda and
false narratives about Ukraine children
are not allowed to speak the Ukrainian
language and forced to attend Russian
language
uh literature and history classes
children are forced to listen to the
Russian Anthem legally sometimes it's
hours a day teenagers teenagers are
recruited into Russian youth military
movement and we have evidence since 2014
that thousand of these kids are now
Russian soldiers fighting against
Ukraine and I told you in our Center
that Mr Bulman that um Russia now
created a military movement called wagon
where Wagner militaries coming to kids
and tell them about their their like
experience of killing
ukrainians and um I am a father myself I
have four children I know many of you
you are fathers and mothers and have
hopes and dreams for the future of your
children I know how you work to Foster
your children identity Ukrainian parents
have the same dream for their children
we dream of having a safe peaceful
prosperous country governed by rule of
law where our children can Thrive
Russian launched their fullscale
Invasion but we haven't lost this this
dream we have a war to win and with you
with your support we will win we must
win because we have no other choice I
appeal to you today to use your voices
to condemn Russian forceable transfer of
Ukrainian children as genocide and to
pursue accountability for perpetrators
of this devastating crime which defies
Humanity in itself help us raise
awareness of this genocide and support
us in our efforts to bring our children
home as you know in April 2023 the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe stated that Russian forceable
transfer of Ukrainian children matches
with the international definition of
genocide it demanded Russia to return
Ukrainian children and punish those
responsible on all levels 6 months later
there is no sign that Russia Hur and
abided by this demand I'm asking you
today to mount diplomatic pressure on
Russia to return our children at the
same time I have no illusions that the
Russia will react on your demand so I'm
asking you about more than diplomatic
pressure I appeal you today to use your
voices to condemn Russ Russian forceable
transfer of Ukrainian children as
genocide I am asking you to provide
political and financial support to
investigations of this transfer I'm
asking the European Union to express
Universal jurisdiction and open
investigation into Russian acts of
genocide against our children thank you
so much and thank you for standing with
us and and going with
us ahead in this very hard
circumstances Mr kba we heard your voice
and we heard your message and we would
like to assure
you that we are standing with you in
this fight and uh let me
also say
how big how great
your example is to your nation as well
to Europe and the whole world what you
are doing with your uh
organization is
showcasing what the fight for Humanity
can provide individually and
collectively for our future we have
direct questions to you please allow
colleagues that we speak uh to mikola
directly because he is rushing forward
in the British Parliament and has more
uh uh collaborators to talk to my first
intervention comes from Yanina
oova uh PPE who is connected uh online
with us khina you can you can see us you
can hear us then you have the
floor
thank you very
much thank you Mr kba I was very moved
by what you had to
say we learned just how many children
had been deported and I put myself the
question as to how they could be brought
back to their families
I know that the process in itself would
be very
difficult you mentioned 200 children
having been
saved so I just wondered what the price
of that was how much does it actually
cost to bring a child back because you
have to search for the child you have to
locate the
child and then you have to bring the
child back and and so all of that must
cost I just wanted to have some idea of
the resources that are
necessary apart from just general
support I imagine financial support is
important and I just wondered how much
by way of resources you would need to
bring a child
back
and then is the expectation that
children would return to Ukraine for or
for example to a country like Poland
because of course there is a war ongoing
in Ukraine the children will also need
psychological support as well as
material support so I'd be interested to
hear from you how you see that process
and I'm very grateful to you for all of
the information that you have given
us I hope that you will be able to bring
the children back as soon as possible
thank you thank you uh Yanina our next
speaker is with us here Cataline CH for
the renew
group yes thank you very much chair um
and many thanks for our uh speakers for
our experts and of course for uh Mr kba
for his truly harrowing and moving
account and of course uh for his
resiliency also to fight for the right
cause in face of unimaginable hardship I
think it's uh
very straightforward to say that we are
all standing behind your cause and this
Parliament has always been and always
will be a very vocal Advocate to sending
up uh for the innocent Ukrainian
children uh who were deported and uh
kept under conditions which should never
take place uh in in in Europe in in 2023
and nowhere in the word and uh for me
really this forcible transfer and the
mass deportation of Ukrainian children
is is one of the most harrowing part of
of the war that's going on in our
Eastern neighborhood but uh also it's
very important to remember that uh this
is not only Russia we should not forget
that lukashenka's belarian regime uh is
also competed in these crimes uh these
atrocious deportations began already in
2014 uh in eastern Ukraine and uh Crimea
so so we have to see the full picture
and uh also so we have to call for the
perpetrators uh on uh every time we have
the transfer to do that uh so I would
have like many questions but now I would
just like to Direct One to Mr KVA
because I know that he has to leave uh
so he briefly uh touched up on the
extremely moving topic of the
re-education camps in Russia and I would
like to ask a little bit more on this
topic uh so do we know the number of
children who are kept in these
facilities uh and also the physical
conditions and like the contents of this
three education
material
uh can you explain to us like how these
facilities can be characterized uh and
uh of course we hear your calls for us
to uh be even more vocal uh also on the
topic of genocide and uh I I think that
this committee is uh very much on in
line with uh supporting your cause with
every means that we have so thank you
very
much thanks K I have one uh more
question to mikola and then Mr kba is in
invited to to reply I give afterwards
the word no I will read out a statement
of our vice president for children's
rights then I will give the floor to our
guests uh right right after we have a
second part uh uh that is introduced by
Anna Wright uh on the deputation of
civilians in general and then we come
back with a second round of comments and
discussions um well of course we heard
um the circumstances and we heard the
plea to put additional pressure on the
public debate this is exactly what we
are going to do and now the question is
uh to uh Mr kba do you see specific
trigger points if you are talking now to
British members of parliament if you are
talking today to us you know we are in
Brussels for the European Union but all
of us are going back also to our
constituencies to Our member countries
on whom especially would you like to
see uh uh additional pressure put
um the national governments the European
Commission of course the European ex
external Action Service we are going to
hear from their activities further on uh
but what is about International
organizations uh ngos who may play a
role uh whoever can be of help if you
can give us more details we are grateful
you have the floor for a final
statement yeah thank you so much thank
you for your questions and um you know
Professor Bulman that it's very very
complicated question who you know when
you're asking me who can help uh of uh
with this issues we have to we have to
we have to know
that
we we have enemies such a big enemy
Russia Federation and Putin who really
want to totally destroy totally erase
our identity and
um it's it's like you asking who in this
Psychiatric Hospital could be the best
doctor I we we cannot heal him from this
idea we can fight we can join our
efforts to
to return more kids to protect to raise
our voices against again this and find
the best Solutions together I don't know
if I I answer your questions but the
main
triggers uh everywhere not in the
British Parliament but everywhere is to
the fathers and mothers to to like to
feel what is my feel if somebody tried
just touch my child because we are
living in the in one Community because
for me Ukraine is the European
Community yeah I I don't want be a
Russian Community I don't want be part
of Russia Empire uh and I don't feel is
the part of Russia and never felt it and
that that's why
we we really ask you we are begging you
just to feel the same feel that you
have in your community
Ukraine your Ukrainian children and uh
and next question was about how many how
can we return more kids and um let me
explain it it's not just about
camps H and our strategy not only return
kids but save Ukraine strategy is to
search to return to recover and to
integrate we we it's it's four processes
and it's all together not just to find
not just to return not just to recover
and and integrate because we have to
build rebuild children's life and um can
you imagine that after
2014 remember this number because I I
mentioned that Maria V belover reported
about
740,000 children who' been registered
after full scale Invasion but alt
together under the Russians after
2014 1.5 million of Ukrainian children
dbas crier new occupied territories and
Russia
it's almost 20% of children's population
and this is not about
camps camps it's only a little piece
it's about brainwashing indoctrinating
russify all of these kids erase the
identity it is genocide not just a camp
Camp is just a little example what we
know but all system of Russian State
working to erase Ukrainian identity
and you asked me about returning
children how much does it cost it is
expensive really just to return one
child we can spend from
$3,000 up to dozens of thousands it
depends of how long time official
Representatives stay there or relatives
how Russia want to block them to be
returned and different things and many
of these things very confidential I
cannot tell you about this because for
Russia save Ukraine is a terroristic
organization because we kidnapping they
you can read this in Russian media we
kidnapping children from new Russian
territory but we just returning
Ukrainian children from occupied
territory from Russia but for Russia we
are terroristic organization and they
recognize any organization who trying to
help kids as a terroristic that's why we
cannot share how we are doing this but
really we need your support we need
support of organization who can support
us financially or different ways it
doesn't matter but which will help uh us
to return more children to Ukraine and
you uh told told us about Poland that
Poland ready to bring these kids and I'm
so grateful that Poland uh where the
biggest number of ukrainians live now
and you let them survive but you know
what is the greatest impression I ask
all kids whom we returned please share
with me your
highlight when you were returning to
Ukraine and they told me when we cross
the Ukrainian border when we've seen
Ukrainian flag and we when we've been on
Ukrainian land they were crying all of
them were crying it's it's so it was so
emotional for them that's why we
understand which circumstances we have
in Ukraine and but we we really want to
bring up our kids at the Patriots the
with the
dignity to fight for our freedom for our
democracy and they are they really Brave
and one more example just just in the
last thing I I remember 12 years old boy
whom We rescued and return from Camp re
educational camp and I asked him can you
share with
me
what what did you afraid what was the
most horrible for you and you really did
you really afraid that you never come
back to Ukraine because many children
told me about it and she told no I did
not afraid because I was sure that I
will come back to home but I asked how I
was dreaming about it every night I was
planning a route and I was planning my
escape and only one thing stopped me I
did not know how I cross the
minefields on the front
line and I planned how to cross
minefields 12 years old boy who planned
cross the minefields just to escape just
to return to his land to Ukraine it is
for me it's a great example of heroism
of Ukrainian children that's why we are
moving ahead rescuing more and more kids
thank you so
much mikola thank you and all the best
of luck for your work uh let me let me
tell you that uh listening to my
colleagues and to my friends here we can
say you are the only you and your
friends you are the only terrorist
organization we dearly love all the best
for you and now I would like to read out
the statement of Eva Kovach our vice
president uh in the European Parliament
coordinator on children's rights dear
chair dear colleagues and invited guests
as I am unable to join this very
important discussion on the measures to
tackle forceable deportation of
Ukrainian children by Russia please rest
reassured that this horrific and
unfortunately still continuing situation
is very high on my agenda as the EP
coordinator on children's rights when in
March we discussed in this committee the
systematic deportation and the so-called
re-education of Ukrainian children by
Russian authorities we knew that we were
looking at planned and coordinated
actions by Russia aimed at depriving
Ukraine of its youngest generation later
in April I discussed this issue in Kiev
with first lady anena shelena and the
presidential commissioner for for
children Miss Daria harash Mish harash
Muk it was very clear to me that
returning Ukrainian children deported to
Russia or detained in occupied
territories Remains the priority for
Ukrainian authorities we know that the
systematic deportation and retention of
children is a key law tactic this is a
cross violation of international inuman
rights law amounting to genocide as
promised during my visit in Kiev I
continue engaging with stakeholders
including the international Committee of
Red Cross special representative of the
Secretary General for children and armed
conflict and Ukrainian bodies and
organizations on this issue I'm very
grateful to the organ organizations on
the ground who are assisting parents and
families but these individual success
stories of safe return while very
welcome and joyful unfortunately do not
address the systematic issue nor the
Damage Done to these children if and
when they do come home that is why
coordinated action at the international
level is needed I do follow the
activities of the work of sa Ukraine
represented here today and I would like
take this opportunity to commend their
Relentless efforts in helping Ukrainian
families reunite with their children I
wish you a fruitful discussion Eva
kopach vice president and European
Parliament coordinator on children's
rights thanks uh very much Eva for your
contribution and now we are uh going
going to our experts are we going to the
external Action Service I'm in the hands
of our excellent secretary what are we
doing
here anna you are ready to intervene and
then uh Cataline comes in with another
question uh dear chair dear members of
the European Parliament thank you for
the chance to speak to you today and uh
the panelist before me have spoken about
Russia illegal transfer and deportation
of Ukrainian children at amnesty we have
documented this PR this practice and the
devastating impact it has on children's
rights uh we have seen causes we have
seen cases of children separated from
their families being forcibly
transferred to Russian occupied areas or
unlawfully deported to Russia this
practice is a war crime and Russia's
efforts to facilitate the adoption of
these children by Russian families
indicate a deliberate policy of
deportation and forceable transfer which
also amounts to a crime against
humanity uh and I personally during my
recent visit to Ukraine spoke to mothers
whose children luckily were returned
back to their families but the suffering
the pain and the impact it has on the
families on children's mental health and
of on parents' mental health is terrible
uh however uh I would like to drawn your
attention today to the thousands of
Ukrainian civilians who are in Russian
captivity because this issue is also
very important and deserves the same
level of international support I believe
as the illegal transfer and deportation
of Ukrainian
children uh as we are all aware human
rights violations and abuses have been a
daily reality for residents of the
Russian occup F Crimea and parts of the
donet and lugansk region since 2014 and
after the full scale Invasion which
happened almost two years ago the scale
of violations and abuses has increased
the human rights situation in the
Russian occupied areas of Ukraine is
very dire and along with physical
violence and the bombardments the
civilian population has to leave in fear
for their life and the life of their
loved ones I was told by one the
residents of occupied part of zoria
region that they live in constant fear
that there is the ongoing campaign to
eliminate everyone who disagrees or
opposes the occupation the campaign to
completely eradicate Ukrainian identity
history and culture uh he told me this
after he himself was intimidated
kidnapped threatened uh and physically
assaulted by the occupation of Russian
authorities and all this were done to
him for his refusal to cooperate and for
his refusal to denounce himself as a
Ukrainian uh and relatives of former
Ukrainian Armed Forces service people
local authorities Crimean tters
Educators and many many others who
survived Russian occupation told me that
while you are living and the territories
under Russian control you must endure
const and ID and phone checks your house
is not safe because it can be broken
into any time of day and night without
any explanation or warrant uh I spoke to
farida she's a wife of an innocent
civilian man from hon region his name is
roslan abdurahmanov and he has been held
in Russian captivity since April 2022
farida told me that seven men broke the
door to their house on 18th of April
2022 they bat my husband in front of me
and our children tied his hands with
sticky tape and put a plastic bag on his
head they covered his face with this
plastic bag and fixed it with sticky
tape around his neck and took him away
next farida heard of her husband was 3
days later on 20th of April 2022 by then
uh her husband roslan was taken from
Heron region to sim fop Crimea uh to a
pre-trial Detention Facility famous
Covan uh and during interrogations
Ruslan was subjected to beatings
electrocutions threats of physical and
sexual violence against him and his
family in sopel in the SEO one he was
placed in an overcrowded cell he's not
allowed to sit during the day the light
is on during night times uh the food and
water very very scare uh I quote just to
keep them alive and uh also he is not
allowed he was not allowed uh any
contact with his family he was denied
access to medical help or access to
lawyer uh and on September uh the 2nd
2022 he was charged by sop District
Court to five years in prison for what
they call participation in illegal armed
formation and uh with this armed
formation the court meant his
Association was the activists supporting
the economic blockade of Crimea after
its occupation in
2014 following this word on 8th of
January 2023 roslan was transferred to a
prison in Russia and he's now serving
his sentence in chilin and chabin is 2
and a half th000 kilomet away from here
region from where his family is and from
home basically and that's a very very uh
popular Trend that Ukrainian civilians
not only they are detained tortured ill
treated but they are also forcefully and
illegally transferred deep into the
Russian Federation territory where they
have no contact with the outside world
or with their
families and unfortunately according to
to the uh omut person of Ukraine there
are around
25,000 cases like Rands 25,000 civilians
who were arbitrarily detained subjected
to enforced disappearance tortured and
then illegally transferred to the
territory of Russian
Federation uh and as as a panelist
before me said these practices they
didn't start on 24th of February 20 22
when the full scale Invasion uh started
there are lots of cases that predate the
full scale Invasion and another case I
would like to bring to your attention
today is the case of Alexander
marenka uh he was detained uh in Russian
occupied dunet back in December
2018 uh his wife cerina told me that
it's draining to live your life when
your loved one is suffering and has an
incredible toll on her mental
health uh Alexander after he was
arbitrarily detained in dunet then was
held in communicado tortured uh in
February 2018 he was forcibly
transferred to kodar that's in the south
of Russia uh and there his detention was
repeatedly extended on fabricated
churches and currently he's serving a
10year sentence in WTI that that's in
East Siberia and that's even further
down in Russia that's like 7,000 kilomet
away from his home from his wife and
from his
country uh additionally Alexander has
serious health issues and no adequate
Medical Care is provided to treat his
condition he is regularly subjected to
harassment from the side of panel Colony
authorities uh including deprivation of
contact with his family
his lawyer or any kind of medical
treatment he
requires and again as kerina says the
hardest part is to realize that there is
no end to this suffering Russian
authorities just keep coming up with new
charges against Alexander and thousands
of other Ukrainian civilians who are
arbitrarily arrested and IL legally
transferred from occupied Ukraine to the
territory of Russia as kerina believes
there is a clear policy to keep this
innocent people captive to have an
exchange fund uh but these people are
civilians not prisoners of war and there
is no legal procedure or mechanism to
exchange a civilian
thees uh and dear members of the
European Parliament we are grateful for
your persistent and unwavering scrutiny
over the gross violations and crimes
committed in the context of Russia's
aggression in Ukraine you repeated
resolutions and expressions of support
are more than ever needed to keep the
situation in Ukraine on the EU agenda
however we believe that more attention
is needed for the thousands of Ukrainian
civilians held in Russian
captivity uh therefore we urge the EU
and the European Parliament to do
everything in your power to ensure that
the Russian Federation stops the
persecution of Ukrainian civilians on
the territory under its control
including arbitrary detentions
imprisonments and unlawful transfer to
Russia that those who were arbitrarily
detained are unconditionally released
and that while in detention everyone is
protected from torture and other ill
treatment the international
organizations including icrc
unhcr and ohcr are given unfettered
access to places of detention we would
also urge the European Parliament to
ensure that the plight of Ukrainian
civilian prisoners is addressed in
European Parliament resolutions and you
statements and that the names and cases
of specific individuals are referred to
in such
resolutions uh that all those
responsible for the unlawful deprivation
of Liberty the forceable transfer to
Russia the violation of fair trial
rights and torture are identified and
brought to Justice this obviously
includes by uring that such violations
are looked into in the ongoing
investigations at the IC and the
national investigations taking place in
EU member states under the principle of
universal
jurisdiction uh we would urge that the
EU and the European Parliament supports
the development of a mechanism to
unconditionally free civilians legally
detained in Russia and their safe return
to Ukraine alone with any person who
were forcibly transferred or deported to
Russia uh that the EU member states
ensure that ukrainians seeking to enter
Europe from Russia are able to access
the EU also in the absence of document
and that obviously the Ukrainian
authorities also prioritize the plight
of Ukrainian civilians in Russian
captivity thank you very
much thank you so much this was Anna
right Regional research covering Ukraine
on behalf of Amnesty International now
we are going the following
steps I will give the floor to Anna
Karen coar for the external Action
Service together with our question we
heard what Anna right was saying on the
deputation of civilians how can we help
how can we be supportive and the
question again also to anite provide us
with a list of BIOS with a list of names
because we would like to become active
in the way that you requested then after
having heard from the external Action
Service I give the floor to members uh I
see Catalin J and then if I may ask your
patience dear guests then I give you the
floor for a final statement in Your
Capacity as um the authors of our study
is that okay for everybody so then we
are turning ourselves to the external
Action Service now please you have the
floor
thank you very much uh Mr chairman and
thank you I'm very very grateful to The
Honorable members to put this very very
important issue on the agenda again and
thanks to speakers from whom we as
always learn a
lot well we know the brutal war of
aggression continues with devastating
impact on civilians and as always it is
the children that that suffer the
most uh um the same day as our meeting
we also had our Foreign Affairs uh
council meeting and the high
representative and vice president borell
said loud and clear that Ukraine is eu's
top priority
so the meeting today cannot be more
timely of course I will focus most in my
intervention on accountability but I'm
of course very happy also to take any
questions or
comments um we have concluded already in
international monitoring mechanism
including by the way the United Nations
Commission of inquiry in its latest
report less than a month ago on 20
October that Russian authorities have
committed a wide range of violations of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law in
Ukraine